there's ralph you probably missed him
robin it's uh i did
hey right now hey i mean everybody's
pretty mental
involved with the show but would you say
sal's probably the most damaged
like who could beat him let me think for
a second ronnie's pretty mental too
i mean let's be honest ronnie has an
anger management issue like on ronnie's
just an angry guy he's ready to burst
yeah but he's really angry but sal is
really crazy
jacob's a [ __ ] mess jason's the mess
jason's a [ __ ] mess just look at it
look at his eyes man he's so
[ __ ] up my eyes yeah man you're you're
out of it you're out of it you're
totally yeah
the eyes are like [ __ ] two pieces of
glass
you see a fancy in his brain like he's
kind of naked
and i'm [ __ ] up well answer your
question ralph i don't really have a
good answer i
you know there's a lot of different
problems i got my own problems so uh
yeah everybody's a little bit [ __ ] up
howard who would you say is the most
well-adjusted person on our staff
i i've said it before i think it's you i
always think it's gary i don't know why
what about you i think will will's
getting
will has so many anger issues this guy
he's a philadelphia eagles fan tell him
will tell him why you're [ __ ] up
you're not in the running for being
well-adjusted
when alcohol gets in the mix it
definitely gets ugly there's no doubt
jets gary and i were at a jets game with
will where we had to break up a fight
before we entered the stadium
that is true why was will fighting with
somebody at the jet game
gary it was no i know what it was it was
we were we were like all
you know edging to get in you know what
everyone's getting in and will was like
dude the [ __ ] i'm standing here
[ __ ] wait for me and the guy goes
[ __ ] you and we'll go
[ __ ] you
my crowning achievement was getting
kicked out of the same baseball game
twice
two tickets yeah that's what i mean
didn't we go to a mets phillies game and
you almost got in a fight with the third
baseman from the mets for y'all
oh yeah i got a rod to get all fired up
one time i was yelling at him
it was great oh he jumped on a woman's
back once he also
went a vikings jersey to an eagles
playoff game she deserved it
he would yell at the ball boy on the
mets these stories are 20 years old by
the way
i've matured over the years